how do you personalize your G suite
admin console to suit your specific
needs
in this quick lab we've provided you
with an organization pre suite labs and
a temporary G suite domain to work in
you will make some basic modifications
to a G suite admin console and then
modify the company profile let's get to
it so far in the lab you've removed and
rearranged some controls from the admin
console dashboard here we are
customizing the company profile and
adding a support message that users will
see when they can't sign into their G
suite account we've set a time zone
relevant to our users and select manual
for new products so that an
administrator must manually add new
products for users to have access in the
lab you will also get the opportunity to
bulk add users using a CSV file and to
log in as one of your newly created
users and experience it from a user
perspective in case you're not familiar
quick Labs is an online hands-on lab
library available 24 hours a day seven
days a week with more than 150 labs on
every cloud topic from intro to expert
level each lab helps you learn a new
skill in about 30 minutes using google
cloud when you're ready
use this link to take the lab we just
went through today and when you're ready
to sign up for GCP use this link to
apply a three hundred dollar credit to
your account we want to hear from you
every week we'll answer a question from
our viewers so let us know what's on
your mind in the comments below
[Music]
you
[Music]